[Music]
all right so we went over a video on the
basic premise of Aikido and what kind of
situations it plays out in and we did an
attack on our video on some of the
attacks which were the dode oriented Ori
and why they exist in Aikido so now
let's look at the common strikes you see
in Aikido and why those common strikes
are maybe different than what you might
expect and what you might even think
those strikes are pretty stupid but I'm
gonna tell you pretty quick that they're
actually super functional so in IKEA we
classically have three strikes we have
what's known as a showman strike that
looks like this okay there are three
variations showman one is hand coming
down from the front hand two is hand
coming down back hand three is hand
coming up forward hand those are all
called showman then we have yokomen
yokomen is back hands coming across
hitting to the side of the head or front
hand coming across to the side of the
head and that's a yokomenuchi and then
last we have skeet which is driving
through just like this now when you see
those you might think they look really
dumb I remember having a problem with
them when I first started saying I was
like well maybe that's some old way
people thought but people don't fight
like that now so I don't know why we
have those so the first first thing to
understand is these are weapon oriented
strikes so for example if Josh and I
were in the kitchen and I'm making a
beautiful omelet and Josh doesn't like
my omelet he insults me and I'm mad
about it right I'm likely to take that
frying pan and smash them on the head
just like this now that's our shomenuchi
strike if we're in a flower shop and
I've made a beautiful arrangement of
flowers and Josh comes in and salts it
and I get furious I might pick up my
vase and smash them on top of the head
like that if we're on the beach and Josh
and I get in a fight and I grab a rock
I'm very likely smashed Josh in the side
of the face like this with a rock right
if I had a knife in my hand and this guy
got a little little mouthy maybe I'm
gonna attack him bang with the back hand
here like this so you can see these
strikes that a second ago looks really
stupid when we put something in your
hand there
natural those are very common strikes
that exist so Shulman and yokomen come
from that basic idea of picking
something up at hand and smashing this
guy over the head the ski so when we
look at the ski and why the ski exists
we have to start to remember the
important distancing in Aikido we have
to understand our ma high so remember in
IQ no we never want to be here with this
guy right this is dangerous to be this
close to someone he can make an action
before I have a chance to react to it so
our minimum safety distance is out here
this is our minimum safety distance now
from this minimum safety distance I
can't make clever little cuts you can
see I have to take a step in to make
clever little cuts so if I take a step
in Josh's answer is simply always to
back out that clever little cutting
range now if I go into a defensive
position Josh should never enter into
this defensive position if he can help
it
he's he gonna get in a bad way so
remember josh is gonna be on the outside
now if I'm getting frustrated right I'm
trying to track this guy down so we're
here and I'm trying to get him if he's
making distance it's very likely that
from here I'm gonna lunge out to try and
get it with a big movement that's where
the idea of ski comes in is being in a
defensive position and trying to make a
large leaping attack so if josh is
always keeping his distance his idea
isn't to get me then that large leaping
distance is what's gonna set up the ski
action all right now that we're
understanding the distance we can
understand why also we wouldn't have
common strikes so what are common
strikes for today
well maybe you think it's a big jab or a
cross or some kind of uppercut or hook
these maybe seem like reasonable those
strikes or a big round cake might be
something that happens or even a front
push kick or something like this if you
study you know cut out they may be a
side kick is what you're thinking about
these are common strikes today for our
context they don't work out the the
reason is josh is always going to make
distance so in order to throw any of
those I have to set myself right so if
you look at it in common box of modern
boxer modern boxer sets themselves in a
stance now the reason they do this is
because they're getting in position to
make power josh wants to box me back so
for in a tournament and we're trying to
box each other back he's gonna stand
he's trying to throw the same kind of
shop I'm trying to throw this it makes
us equal this means that I can get to my
distance and throw a powerful shot
ideally where I want to hopefully he's
gonna want to push the exchange and I'm
better close up and I'll do really well
and I you know though he always wants to
make distance so for example if I'm
trying to set my stance
Josh will just make more distance right
so that means I've got to track him down
I'll start to walk and then when I reset
he'll make more distance so before you
know it
he's very far away from me and Ike you
know we're never going to allow someone
to set in position and stand in front of
him if they set into position we
immediately move away that means he
can't be in this comfortable boxing
stand also means throwing the kick is
very very difficult now maybe some fancy
flying spinning kick or something might
may have a chance of being thrown some
of the practices running a lot and
throwing it but in general that's gonna
be a one-off a big lunging shot and he's
not gonna stand there while I try and
round kick him the reason is he's not
trying to hit me back in this jaw she's
always just trying to be freeze never
trying to exchange blows with me or
prove that he's more clever and more
skilled at me in that range and I can oh
we always assume they're better they're
stronger than faster all those things
than us so that stuff's not going to
work out so josh is making distance
which means I'm limited to large lunging
strikes when we do that okay so when
we're turning to talk about the strikes
that you see in Aikido their common
strikes is someone had a weapon and
they're just smashing it they're never
trained strikes like boxers or kickbox
there's nothing we'll throw because
we're not gonna allow the distance for
that to happen now that's not to say
that we couldn't ever get in those
ranges maybe we could but the answer to
that is actually steady boxing or
kickboxing if you want to be good at
those things if you want to do the
Aikido thing then what you want to do is
never get in that range and never let
them set those up the only way they're
gonna come in for a strike is to lunge
in so talk to speaking of lunging in
what will we do when they lunge in check
that out on the next video